allo il est 15 heures je suis désolé il
m'a agressé à la seconde même où je suis
entré pourquoi vous êtes partis habiter
à seattle ces sommes qui voulait
déménager et si je lui avais demandé
thomas il aurait refusé alors j'ai rien
dit désolé mais je suis super en retard
fouzia c'était quoi ça l'information
reste à confirmer mais un tremblement de
terre aurait frappé la côte
californienne
une panne électrique touche ouest des
états unis et l'enfant on espérait que
tu ton vol je savais pas où elle est a
pu joindre récemment on a été coupée
qu'est ce qu'il a dit juste avant elle
était terrifiée
[Musique]
bon résumons la situation on sait pas ce
qui se passe et des avions de chasse
faune des vols de reconnaissance
ma fille et elle est toute seule à 3000
km alors je te pose la question tu viens
avec moi ou pas
pourquoi ses finances du gouvernement
quelqu'un sait quelque chose on sait pas
on va bien
matt bonnes raisons d'être inquiets il
ya un véritable danger
vous auriez pu me dire que vous aviez
une arme je suppose que tu t'es jamais
servi d'une arme à feu
j'ai vu des simulations de jeu de guerre
les mêmes événements
des jeux conçus pour effacer tout
comportement rationnel face à un
incident singulier j'avais encore jamais
vu un ciel comme ça
je veux que tu me permets tu que tu
verras toujours sur ma fille
vous avez ma parole et nous barre la
route
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
trouvais pas ça va s'arranger
tu crois vraiment